hi everyone welcome to connecting to
cloud sql from kubernetes
my name is curtis van gin i'm a
developer programs engineer and i work
on google cloud platform to make the
developer experience
better for developers like you today
we're going to be talking about
how to connect to cloud sql from
kubernetes we're going to have three
main points
the first is we're going to cover how to
connect to cloud sql in general
then we're going to narrow down and talk
about connecting from kubernetes
to cloud sql and then finally we're
going to narrow down even more and do a
hands-on example
of the best practices for connecting the
kubernetes
before we begin there's some basics that
you should understand before we start
uh first it's expected that you know and
understand cloud sql
and how a managed database works what
some of the benefits are and when you
should try and use one
second it's uh understood that you
should understand
the basics of a container the how
container images work and what some of
the benefits for containerization are
and finally we hope that you understand
some of the basics at least of
kubernetes and you understand some
concepts such as pod
and deployments
first let's talk about connecting to
cloud sql
when you're connecting there's two
different things you need to think about
first the path how am i going to reach
the instance and the second is
authorization how do i get permission to
talk to the instance
when you're selecting a path you have
two different options the first option
is public ip
public ip is a static ipv4 address
that's accessible from the public
internet
as long as you have access to the
internet you can potentially connect to
your cloud sql instance
by default authorization is required
since we don't want anyone connecting to
your application that has access to the
internet some of the benefits
of public ip is that you can connect
from outside gcp
well one of the drawbacks is you may
have higher latency since you're
connecting over the internet instead of
using an internal network
the second option you have is to connect
using privateip
privateip is an ipv4 address that's
peered into your project
via a virtual private cloud or vpc for
shorts
by default authorization is not required
but you do have to be on the vpc to
access your cloud sql instance
one of the benefits of private ip is you
usually have lower latency
this is because you're not connecting
over the internet and instead connecting
directly through an internal network
once you've decided how to connect the
next step is authorization
when it comes to authorization there's
three different options you have to look
at
the first is the cloud sql proxy the
cloud sql proxy is a binary that
provides im authentication
it uses a service account to provide
authorization and stock encryption
using short-lived ssl certificates the
second option you can use
is authorized networks this is where you
specify a list of ip addresses that are
authorized to connect
for private ip there's a similar feature
called vpc egress firewall rules
that you can use instead the third
option is self-managed ssl
you can create ssl certificates for your
instance that it can be distributed to
your application
that encrypt your connections for mysql
and postgres this is a client and
server-side
credential while for sql server this is
only a server-side credential
it's important to remember that these
options are for authorization
only you still have to authenticate with
the database
using your username and password
so to summarize you have private ip and
you have public ip
for public ip you have to use either the
cloud sql proxy
or authorized networks we also recommend
that if you are using authorized
networks that you use self-managed ssl
this encrypts your data and makes sure
that no one else can read it in transit
unless they have the certificates
however this is automatically done by
the cloud sql proxy so if you decide to
use it you won't have to worry about
managing your own ssl
when it comes to public versus private
use whichever one works best
and for authorization while we recommend
the cloud sql proxy it's perfectly okay
to use authorized networks and
self-managed ssl as well
next let's talk about kubernetes to
cloud sql
there are three different ways that
you're going to see people recommending
you to connect
the first is you can connect directly
using private ip
the second is you can run the proxy as a
service and finally you can run the
proxy as a sidecar
this is our recommended solution over
the first two
because private ip doesn't require any
authorization it's possible to just
connect directly you can just put in the
private ip
into your application and connect that
directly to your cloud sql instance
in order to access that private ip you
have to be on
a vpc native google kubernetes engine
cluster
now this means that it has to be a gke
cluster if you're using a cluster off
that
off gcp you won't be able to connect
now you may be thinking if it's so easy
to use private ip do i still want to use
the proxy
with the proxy there's the downside of
the initial setup being a little bit of
a hassle
but the upside is you get strong im
authentication
and strong encryption for all the data
from your application
for the proxy the advantage is you don't
have to worry about the setup you can
connect directly via ip
but it requires a vpc native cluster so
if you're connecting from off gke
you don't have that option and there's
weak authorization
anyone on your cluster could potentially
connect to your database
why is iam so important like why do we
push the proxy so hard well
the reason is is that you can use a
service account to represent your entire
application
it gives you a one-to-one mapping of
permissions to applications which makes
it easy to manage
if you decide that an application no
longer has need to access a database
you can simply remove the permission and
it no longer can even if
the changes to the app are made finally
it
follows the principle of least privilege
the app only has the minimum permissions
that are needed which is a great
security advantage
when you're running the proxy as a
service typically you do it as a
separate deployment from your
application
so you can see on the left here we have
our application pods being deployed
and on the right we have our proxy pods
being deployed now your application is
going to connect directly to the proxy
and then your proxy is going to route
your connection right to cloud sql
one of the downsides to this is the
traffic between your application and the
proxy is not encrypted by default
the proxy doesn't offer any encryption
on the client side it only encrypts the
traffic coming out before it gets
connected to cloud sql
another disadvantage is no authorization
anyone on your cluster can connect to
the proxy which means anyone in your
cluster can connect to cloud sql this
negates the advantage i was talking
about before with cloud sql im
authentication
another disadvantage is there is a
single point of failure if all of the
applications are using a single
deployment of the proxy to run
if that deployment fails all of your
applications are no longer able to
connect
if something goes wrong in the proxy and
it stops operating correctly
all of your applications fail instead of
just one instance
finally another disadvantage is the
application and proxy aren't necessarily
running in the same zone or region
this adds additional latency because now
your application has to jump
first to your proxy and then to the
cloud sql instance which could be in an
entirely different region
zone as well by keeping the application
and proxy together you can eliminate
this meaning you only have to worry
about the latency to the cloud sql
instance
this is why we recommend running the
proxy as a sidecar
it's called a sidecar pattern because if
you think of a motorcycle with a sidecar
it's attached to the side you still have
your main application here in the middle
and then you have the cloud sql proxy
attached to the side right here
the application can connect to the cloud
sql proxy directly which then connects
to cloud sql
because this is a pod it's an atomic
unit meaning the application and the
cloud sql proxy are always together
if the cloud sql proxy fails the
application has also failed
if the application fails the cloud sql
proxy is still running in the other pods
it's authorized because the cloud sql
proxy is inside the same pot as the
application
only the application can access it and
you don't have to worry about other
traffic
accessing the proxy that's not supposed
to
it's also isolated if the application
fails or the proxy fails you don't have
to worry about the rest of your
application going down
it's just that pod that fails
and finally it's encrypted the minute
the data leaves your cloud sql proxy it
is encrypted
and sent to your cloud sql instance
before it's unencrypted
this means you don't have to worry about
anybody potentially listening in between
your application and your proxy
okay so you're convinced you want to use
the cloud sql proxy in the sidecar
but how let's talk about deploying the
proxy as a sidecar
again there's two different things you
need to think about the first is you
need to decide how to pass credentials
into the proxy
once you've decided that you just have
to mount the proxy as a sidecar onto an
existing application
when you're passing credentials again
you have a couple of choices to make
the first is workload identity this is
where you can map a google service
account or gsa for short
to a kubernetes service account or ksa
for short
the advantage of this is you don't have
to worry about managing any secrets
but it is a gke only feature this means
you'll have to use a gke cluster if you
want to take advantage of this
if you're not using a gte cluster or if
you're operating
somewhere that doesn't have workload
identity you can still use a service
account key file
this is where you have service account
credentials that are stored in a json
key file
the downside is you have to worry about
keeping track of that json key file and
rotating it
but you are able to do this on a
standard kubernetes instance
so option one workload identity for gke
if you look to the left over there
you'll see the application the cloud sql
proxy
what happens when you decide you need
application default credentials is the
client library including the cloud sql
proxy can reach out to the metadata
server this is true for both the
application and the proxy so you can use
one service account to represent
both things once the cloud sql proxy
makes that call
it gets the token that it needs to
authorize with the instance and uses it
to make any api calls necessary
in order to set this up the first thing
you'll need to do is create a kubernetes
service account
this is a fairly simple deployal and can
be a config.eml that's stored along with
your application's deployment
step two is need to bind your google
service account to the kubernetes
service account
this is two steps it's one gcloud
command that specifies
which google service account you're
using and which kubernetes service
account
and then it's the second step in cubectl
to connect your kubernetes service
account
finally once you've done the first two
steps you need to add the
kubernetes service account to your
application all you need to do is add
the service account name that you
specified in the first step
and then bound in the second step to
make sure that your application uses it
when it's deployed next
gte will automatically handle the
metadata server for you as long as the
option is enabled on your cluster
the second option you have is the
service account key file in this case
both the application and the proxy are
going to load the credentials
from a file and then use that credential
to generate the tokens needed to make
any api calls
step one is you have to create a service
account key so once you have your google
service account created you can use a
quick gcloud command to create a local
key.json file
step two is you want to turn the key
into a secret
using cube ctl you can create a generic
secret with whatever name you prefer
and you can use a specific file name
and load it from that local file in this
case we're using service account.json
and we're loading it in from key.json
which we created in step one
step three is we want to mount as a
volume what this is going to do is put
inside your pods file system the file
that you've created as a secret
and make it accessible for your
application to access
once you've mounted it as a file both
the application and the proxy can read
it in
and use it when it's creating api calls
now after you've decided how you're
going to mount the credentials you just
need to
mount the proxy itself as a sidecar in
this case the proxy runs in its own
container
and it shares a pod with the main
application
this means it's really easy to take your
existing configuration and add the cloud
sql proxy to it
you can see above we have a pretty
standard containers deployment
here where you have a list of containers
that you're using your cloud sql proxy
on this top half here we have things
like the environment variables you're
using to configure your database
see this one is database user which is
created from a secret
we also have the name of the application
in any other configuration such as image
or whatever you're deciding to use
on top of that you can specify the name
of the cloud sql proxy
so you add as a separate entry in your
list here image cloud sql docker
gce proxy this is an image that we
maintain for you so that you can use it
second you just need to add the command
that you want the cloud sql proxy to run
so here we just have cloud sql proxy if
you're using private ip
you want to enable the ip addresses
types flag and set it equal to private
and if you're using a service account
you want to make sure that you have the
credential file flag as well to tell it
where exactly that service account is
located
finally you'll use the instances flag to
pass in the name of the instance and the
tcp port you want to listen to
you can use whatever tcp port you want
or you can just default to the standard
for mysql postgres or sql server
if you're interested in learning more
here's some additional resources you can
take a look at
the first is the cloud sql proxy which
is open source written go
available on github the second is the
cloud sql jdbc socket factory
this can be used by java users to
connect directly to your cloud sql
instance without using the proxy in a
similar manner
if you're interested in finding more
please take a look at the repos if you
encounter any issues
please open an issue on github and let
us know
thanks for watching and have a great day
you